Any idea why I lost improvement on my gut healing protocol?
I read that eating rice increases butarate, so maybe that sudden change since I
didn't normally eat rice caused the regular bowel movements, but only for a
while. Should I add a small amount of chicken back yellow zone item? Yeah, I would
say I would say try that. Again, the yellow zone items, things you want to add
back soon or then later. So yes, and this is going to be experimental for you. So yeah,
that would be a good experiment. Maybe I'm not getting an
protein, that's why I got a cold. You could be onto something there totally. I had
white, I had blood labs run a couple days before I started having symptoms and I
don't think anything was off either clump or he ran a crit. So if you look for,
I'm going to the cold you look for if your white blood cells were off and your
breakdown of white blood cells called the differential was off too. But yeah, I think
you're out of something. I would maybe think of doing that adding chicken back
with making some chicken soup would be a good thing. I think that might be good.